you have the honor of being the first
chapter
of antifa in the hamptons
why am i the leader because i am in the
system
but i have defected and now i agree with
you we are going to topple the
patriarchy and what
is the patriarchy jeff goldstein jeff
goldstein who's [ __ ] my ex-wife
correct
we're going to dismantle capitalism and
what is capitalism any hedge fund that's
bigger than yours any hedge fund bigger
than mine correct
i have heard that certain people at the
irs
are transphobic what we're gonna have to
do is get in there
and let them know that this is
unacceptable behavior
the irs are the cops too you will all
have a mini child's golf club for
self-defense we will train on a plush
giraffe that i bought for my daughter
before my wife won custody of her
you're trying to [ __ ] my ex-wife is that
what you're doing
you're trying to destroy your family you
will train
day and night on the giraffe until you
are ready for hand-to-hand combat
my commitment to social justice
is unparalleled i don't care what i have
to do
everybody that doesn't have a club has a
pool noodle because you cannot handle
the clubs yet
you will graduate to club now remember
you don't work for george soros anymore
you work for me